today we're going to be speaking with
gary stevenson who's an inequality
economist and former interest rates
trader uh gary really great having you
on i appreciate your time
thanks for having me
so i mean maybe just to start with a
little bit about your background
interest rates trading how how does that
work and with whom are you trading
okay so i worked as an interest rate
trader from 2008 to 2014 at citibank
just hearing a skyscraper off to my left
um
2008 you probably remember with the year
of the great financial crisis yes at
that time all the interest rates in the
whole world went to zero so as an
interest rate trader my job was
basically to bet on when will those
interest rates come back up again which
is kind of a proxy for when will the
economy recover
um
you expect that when the economy
recovers we get demand coming back and
rates start to come back up what's
interesting about that is
every single year from 2008 to 2020
markets predicted that rates would be
normalized the following year which was
wrong almost every single year so um i
made a lot of money by betting that they
would stay zero for a long time
one of the criticisms that many will
make about um
that that type of industry
is that it is not economically
stimulative in the way that making shoes
and selling shoes to someone who then
then wears them is right this is a
common criticism that we hear about
derivatives trading and and financial
markets wall street etcetera having been
inside of it how do you feel about that
claim that trading interest rates
compared to for example running a
restaurant or a dry cleaning business or
manufacturing eyeglasses are
fundamentally different in terms of what
they do for the economy
yeah listen you won't get much argument
from me i'm afraid i didn't go into that
industry to be economically productive
or stimulative i went into industry
because i was really poor and i didn't
want to be poor anymore right and um
from that perspective it worked
um
what i would say is you know i've worked
in economics for a long time now in a
lot of different spaces so i've worked
in finance
i've got a master's degree from oxford
university here in england i've been in
media talking about economics for a
while now i've been sort of bouncing
around sort of activism think tanks and
what i will say is
the markets are the only place where
somebody like me can be the number one
guy within a couple of years
because if you're really really good and
you're right year after year you get
noticed and you know i put an article
out two years ago at the beginning of
kobe saying that
we're going to see at the end of cobit a
massive crisis of inequality of
inflation of cost of living and um i put
a video on youtube saying the same thing
those predictions
were exactly correct
now i did the same thing when i was
working as a trader and within a year
two years you're famous but in this
world if you're right
people are not really risen to the top
so what i would say is
trading is an interesting space because
a young guy a poor background can get
famous by being right in economics and
there's not that many spaces where you
can do that outside of that
so you mentioned inequality and i want
to focus in on that a little bit
you know
sometimes discussions about inequality
particularly in in the uk in the united
states the conversations become sort of
like ethical and moral conversations
uh do does does a wealthy country have a
responsibility or a duty to provide some
bottom some floor to standard of living
and who has earned what or who deserves
what that's one side of the discussion
and different people might have
different feelings about that
i've also argued from an economic and
financial standpoint that there should
be an incentive for the wealthy
uh to also guarantee some minimum
standard of living and reduce inequality
because it's also if you consider a sort
of demand side stimulus approach it's
also good for the rich people it's good
for the businesses it's good to have
more potential customers who can afford
whatever it is that you're selling and
having reduced inequality reduces crime
it reduces a lot of other costs now i i
would still make a moral and ethical
case as well but i want to explore maybe
the financial and economic case to be
made does that track with your beliefs
about the damaging reality of inequality
yeah 100 i mean look i don't come from a
political family i didn't want to be an
activist i didn't want to be a political
youtuber which in a sense is what i've
become
um but my job was to bet on the future
of the global economy
and
i worked in an industry where every
single year
the market as a whole said next year
things will get better and for the first
three years i worked in the industry
things didn't get better
um and you know this is a problem right
like if you if you have a doctor who
says every patient is going to get
better and the patients keep dying
you've got a problem right because these
guys the economist and it's not just
traders it's also guys in central banks
in government in academia they keep
saying things are going to get better
and things don't get better right so
it's clearly a fundamental problem then
for me
you know i i thought a lot about what
what is the reason why we're not getting
the recovery basically what is the
fundamental reason i think
i think actually one of the reasons why
i was able to be such a successful
trader and at one point i was a
citibank's most profitable trader in the
world is because i actually am one of
the few traders who comes from a very
poor background so in the after the 2008
financial crisis when we weren't getting
that recovery
we had to ask this question of why
aren't people spending more money
well i was one of the few people who
could go and ask my friends and family
ordinary people why are you spending
more money and listen ask people now
nine times out of ten you'll get the
same answer because we don't have any
more money right
and if the vast majority of people don't
have any extra money to spend you are
going to have economic crisis of demand
and that's where we've been for you know
15 years essentially so for me
this is and of course you're 100 right
when you say that there's a moral
ethical argument here but there's also a
100 plain economic argument and
i'm not just saying this from a moral
standpoint i've made millions of pounds
betting on this if you do not deal with
inequality it is inevitable that your
economy will decline and decline over
time
i'm curious
do you have a sense of the the
prevailing political views amongst the
who the people that were your fellow
traders i mean was was it a sort of
supply-side right-leaning group of
people were what was it like
so
trading is an elite profession in the
sense that it's one of the best paid
professions you can you can get into
so for that reason
nowadays very very few people get in who
are not from originally pretty wealthy
backgrounds so you're getting people
coming in generally who are quite
wealthy
a lot of them have got economics degrees
and i think when someone has an
economics degree they tend to have kind
of
absorbed into themselves some certain
ideas which which you might describe as
quite right-wing ideas um
but at the same time and what i think is
interesting about trading is these guys
are very very
strongly rewarded for being right and
harshly punished for being wrong
so i think especially people who i
worked with
you know
i've said it here i was one of the most
probable traders at the bank and i was
very vocal about it i always said look
we are never going to get an economic
recovery because of a crisis of
inequality you know and i was saying
that in 2010 2011. so obviously people
who are working with me then
they see that i've been right for 10 11
12 years
um in that world the main thing is that
you have to be right
so i think people who i've worked with
tend to
you know eventually they see these guys
want to make money and they see the guy
who's right every year and that's me so
they come around to my point of view
which is okay inequality is killing the
economy the problem is inequality is not
killing the economy for everyone right
for rich people inequality is absolutely
fantastic and these guys are making half
a million pounds a year a million pounds
a year
so
as much as they can see that there's a
disaster happening they're not the best
incentivize to fix it
when it comes to reducing inequality um
there's a lot of different ideas and
approaches they're often very much tied
into one's prevailing political beliefs
and it's not just a question of what
does the economics necessarily show
what sort of framework or approach
do you think would be the most effective
so i think there's there's basically two
two ways to answer that question one is
what would be technically the most
effective way to reduce inequality and
one is what is politically achievable
okay because this is a really like hot
political conversation right now the
thing which i generally tend to advocate
for is a wealth tax because i think that
is the one which we're most likely to
get people on board with but you know
there are loads of ways you could reduce
inequality you know you could for
example bring in
you could encourage or force the rich to
spend much much much more money which
would drive wages up and give us an
economic boom you know this would be
effective as well but i think what's
important to understand is
in the absence of intervention
inequality rises super super quickly and
this is like a very simple thing which i
think people need to understand when
people have high amounts of wealth that
wealth makes wealth so if somebody has
say 100 million dollars they're gonna
make in an average year three five
million dollars from that money
so these guys will get much much richer
over time and you know in the first year
of kobe i think the first two years the
average billionaire doubled their wealth
in the u.s so these guys will get richer
if we don't do anything so i think
it's really a case of how do you prevent
the crisis from worsening but i think
you have to look at the tax system
because at the moment we have a tax
system where look i come from a poor
background i made millions of dollars i
paid 50
but if you come from a wealthy
background and you have money in the
family you can pay nothing and you can
be much much richer than i am so if you
have a system where the super rich pay
nothing and people like me pay 50
inequalities are never begun arise
right and this is where you start to get
into resistance where you will hear sort
of like
pre-packaged talking points like for
example
if you do that you will kill innovation
and the job creating wealthy will not uh
create jobs and you know when i look at
it i think to myself
the cost of hoarding the money has to be
high that's how you incentivize people
to do something more productive with the
money make it expensive to just sit and
earn the interest which sounds sort of
like what you're saying here
but look there's two ways there's two
things that you need to grow the economy
yeah of course you need people making
investments so that you can have
those productive investments in growth
but you also need demand right look i'm
a wealthy person okay i live off my
investments i live off my investment
income
it is very very hard to make productive
real investments in this economy and you
know we've had
12 13 years of zero interest rates
effectively negative real interest rates
interest rates still are aggressively
negative right what that means is
if you are a rich person you cannot get
any interest on your money so there
should be huge amounts of money flooding
into investments but why aren't there
it's because the customers are not there
there's not enough customers to create
that real growth you need two things you
need two sides of the coin you need
customers who can spend and you need
people who can save and invest but when
inequality gets too high then all of
that money is flowing to the super rich
who are trying to invest it but there
are no customers at the end to spend and
and you you see these crisis of demand
and i think when we're in a situation of
15 years negative interest rates these
supply side arguments have to be dead
they have to be dead you would not get
15 years of negative interest rates if
the problem was not enough people
investing their money
this next question may be tough because
the current tax rates are different in
different countries and you know here in
the united states we have a progressive
income tax and then we also have capital
gains and there's short-term capital
gains and long-term capital gains and
one movement is well tax capital gains
as income taxes which would be much
higher this would be a way to make it
to better incentivize the rich to spend
and put that money into something other
than just collecting the gains the tax
rates are different in the uk they're
different in all these different
countries do you have some sense of what
a more realistic framework should be
about two things one
where
income tax rates should be but maybe
just as importantly capital gains
because capital gains rates being lower
is often a way for the wealthy to avoid
income taxes altogether
so i think
there's two things to think about one is
the rate
and one is avoidance largely legal
avoidance yeah so i think one thing that
needs to be recognized about capital
gains is you pay capital gains when you
sell correct so imagine you have a
wealth of 100 million dollars which
means you're making three five million
dollars income a year on your wealth
are you ever gonna sell
well you're never gonna have to sell
right you're making three five million
dollars a year income so rich people
never have to sell if you're super rich
you never have to sell so the first
thing is so you can bring the rate up to
wherever you want you know these guys
never sell they're never gonna pay and
there is a movement to say okay well we
need to tax unrealized gains
um
the most important thing is it needs to
work it needs to work in the sense of it
needs to effectively tax the very
richest in society right because i know
there are people in the middle that are
worried you're going to try and attack
super rich they're going to avoid it and
then it's going to fall on me and if
that is what happens then it will be a
failure so this needs to be rigorously
tested against does it work on the very
very rich the richest you know is jeff
bezos going to pay is elon musk going to
pay are they going to continue to pay
very little tax on their wealth so
raising tax on capital gains raising the
rate is one thing but you need to get
rid of evasion um i think really what
you need to look at is what is
somebody's
income over the course of their whole
life and how much tax they pay that
should be the measure how much wealth
does this guy have and how much taxes he
paid
and if we're talking about numbers of
less than less than 30 20 for people who
are billionaires you've messed up and
you need to fix it right is there one
particular mechanism that you have found
is most resistant to avoidance
um
to be honest
the problem is often these taxes are
brought in
with avoidance kind of in mind because
you have to consider the game the
politicians are playing on the one hand
most ordinary people actually want the
rich to pay higher taxes they don't
think it's fair that the rich pay lower
taxes than the rest of us they want
higher taxes but the political parties
are funded by super rich people who
don't want to pay taxes so how can you
make both of these groups happy what you
can do is you can bring in a tax that's
called the wealth tax but you can put
loopholes in it such that the superior
can avoid it and then everybody wins
right you can say to ordinary people we
brought the tax in and you can say to
the rich well it doesn't matter because
you don't have to pay it right so i
think there's a real problem here of
politicians you know often they
themselves are super wealthy or become
super wealthy after leaving office and
they're not well incentivized to bring
in a system that works i think you know
anything could work really a capital
gain system could work and inheritance
tax system could work i've got ideas
about putting wealth into a time limit
trust such you can only give it to your
kids for a certain amount of time all of
these things could work but they will
only work with serious political will
behind them to actually make them
effective because at the moment the
incentivization of the politicians is to
pretend to tax the rich but actually not
tax the rich and that's why a lot of the
work i do is talking directly to
ordinary people because these are the
guys who have been hurt by the system
you currently have
yeah a depressing but accurate note to
end on i guess i would say uh gary
stevenson inequality economist former
interest rates trader really appreciate
your time and insights today gary thanks
dave